monsieur je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous remercie de votre disponibilité
pour répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des fédérations françaises de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif le 20
juillet dernier l'Assemblée nationale a
décidé de sa création à la suite de très
nombreuses révélations publiques de
sportifes et sportifs et de diverses
affaires judiciaires ayant trait à la
gestion de certaines fédérations nos
travaux porte sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuelles ou
psychologiques dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématique qui à la gouvernance
financière des organismes de gouvernance
du monde sportif footballeur
professionnel de 1991 à 2008 vous avez
évolué au poste de défenseur à Monaco
puis en Italie à Parme et à la Juventus
de Turin avant d'achever votre carrière
au FC Barcelone en Espagne vous avez été
sélectionné 142 fois en équipe de France
masculine champion du monde en 1998 et
d'Europe en 2000 vous avez remporté
plusieurs titres nationaux ainsi que la
coupe de l'UFA en
1999 en 2008 vous avez créé la Fondation
lilianturam éducation contre le racisme
ce qui témoigne de votre engagement
contre le racisme et les discriminations
sujet sur lequel nous avons également
plusieurs essais vous avez également été
membre du Haut Conseil à
l'Intégration il nous a semblé important
de vous recueill de recueillir votre
témoignage en particulier sur la
question du racisme dans le sport et le
football sujet sur lequel vous vous êtes
exprimé récemment dans un entretien au
journal Le Monde deux questions pour
entamer notre échange quel appréciation
portez-vous sur l'ampleur du phénomène
raciste dans le sport et son évolution
depuis le début de votre carrière deème
le cadre existant pour prévenir détecter
et sanctionner les actes de racisme dans
le sport vous paraît-il adapté je
rappelle que cette audition est ouverte
à la presse et qu'elle est retransmise
en direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale et avant de vous laisser la
parole et d'entamer nos échanges je vous
rappelle que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relatif au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
entendues par une commission d'enquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité je
vous invite donc à lever la main droite
et à dire je le jure après avoir activé
votre
micro
toute la vérité je le jure très bien je
vous remercie vous avez la parole quand
vous avez terminé vos propos vous ferme
votre micro ok très bien merci à vous
ben écoutez merci de m'avoir
invité alors lorsqu'on parle du racisme
dans le
football ce qui est intéressant c'est
c'est pas quand je jouais moi en tant
que que professionnel ou en tant que
jeune au centre de formation je dirais
que la première fois que j'ai subi le
racisme en tant que enfant qui regardait
un match de foot ça remonte à loin en
fait c'est-à-dire que
c'était des
insultes envers Joseph Antoine belle un
gardien qui a joué à Bordeaux à
Marseille je me souviens quand j'étais
enfant et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que nous sommes en
2023 en fait ça existe encore
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des joueurs
encore aujourd'hui qui se font insulter
par des supporters dans des stades de
foot moi-même quand j'étais en Italie ça
s'est passé j'ai eu j'ai subi des
épisodes aussi une fois lorsque je je
jouais
à à Parme contre l'Atletico de Madrid en
fait bon vous savez euh ouais si on veut
analyser l'évolution on voit que ça n'a
pas beaucoup évolué mais en même temps
euh c'est à l'image du racisme qu'il y a
dans la société euh très souvent
lorsqu'il y a un problème de racisme
dans les stades notamment c'est très
amusant parce
que les présidents les dirigeants ils
disent ouais non mais c'est pas des
vrais supporters ou même les
journalistes souvent ils disent ouais
non mais c'est pas des vrais supporters
c'est-à-dire que tout d'un coup ils ont
des comportements raciste et ça devient
des pas des supporters en fait on ne
sait pas qui ils sont et je pense qu'il
y a une
vraie une certaine hypocrisie à ne pas
vouloir voir la réalité du du problème
et moi personnellement je prends ça
comme un un mépris très profond un
mépris très profond euh parce que
comment vous pouvez
avoir dans vos équipes de jeunes dans
vos équipes professionnelles des joueurs
noirs et et et de ne pas être
sensibilisé à ce sujet en disant
que que c'est pas bien grave en fait
mais je pense que c'est encore une fois
c'est lié à la société dans laquelle
nous vivons nous sommes dans un pays
aussi où ça reste tabou de parler de ces
sujetslà et moi je pense qu'au contraire
il faudrait en parler discuter
sensibiliser les gens pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre que chacun de nous
nous faisons partie du problème et de la
solution
voilà pour la deuxème question
c'était la deuxième question c'était le
cadre existant pour prévenir détecter et
sanctionné est-ce que ça vous paraît
suffisant bah il faut croire que
non vu que ça ça perd dur dans le temps
et moi je je reste persuadé
que en fait il faut sensibiliser les
gens il faut éduquer les gens à
comprendre
qu'effectivement il y a il y a des
choses à faire et que la neutralité dans
dans dans la dénonciation du racisme
n'existe pas et moi je pense que par
exemple que ce soit les éducateurs les
entraîneurs les dirigeants devrai être
formés à comprendre
cela par
exemple en fait il faut analyser regardz
ce qui se passe dans l'article dans le
monde j'essaie d'expliquer regardez ce
qui se passe quand il y a un problème de
racisme sur le terrain c'està dire que
il y a des supporters il y a l'arbitre
il y a les deux équipes tout le monde
voit ce qui se passe et souvent en fait
le joueur qui subit le racisme
effectivement est déstabilisé parce que
c'est une violence le racisme et donc
vous demandez de l'aide vous allez voir
l'arbitre en lui disant mais attendez
mais vous voyez pas ce qui se passe et
l'arbitre il vous demande de vous calmer
calmez-vous monsieur calmez-vous donc
effectivement lorsque vous subissez une
violence en fait c'est très difficile
d'être calme et donc il recommence un
peu à demander à l'arbitre qu'est-ce
qu'on fait l'arbitre souvent lui donne
un carton
jaune c'est ça il lui donne un carton
rouge c'est-à-dire reste
calme bien évidemment pris dans les
émotions il continue et souvent ça finit
par un carton rouge on lui demande de
sortir du terrain il sort du terrain le
match continue en fait lorsqu'on analyse
ce qui se passe sur le terrain c'est ce
qui se passe dans la société en règle
générale c'est-à-dire que la société ne
veut pas être confronté à la réalité du
racisme et donc il faut éliminer celui
qui subit le racisme et on peut
continuer et donc moi je pense
qu'effectivement au sein des clubs au
sein des fédérations il y a un vrai
travail à faire de
sensibilisation mais quand je parle de
sensibilisation il faut que ce soit
obligatoire c'est pas des réunion ou ou
si vous si vous êtes si vous avez le
temps vous y passez non c'estàd d que
dans la remise des diplômes il faudrait
qu' qu'il y ait un module obligatoire
pour aborder ces sujets que ce soit le
racisme le sexisme
l'homophobie pour
que que tout le monde soit sensibilisé
sachant qu'en plus le foot c'est le
sport numéro 1 quand même c'est-àdire
que il y a plus de combien de 2 millions
de licenciés donc ça veut dire 2
millions de licenciés les frères et
sœurs le papa la maman ça fait beaucoup
de monde quand même et donc je pense que
ce serait extraordinaire si le monde du
foot pouvait prendre conscience qu'on
pouvait changer les choses dans la bonne
direction et justement pouvez-vous nous
présenter la Fondation que vous avez
créé donc fondation lianturam
l'éducation contre le racisme
pouvez-vous nousésenter les objectifs de
cette fondation les actions qu'elle
conduit est-elle soutenue par les
pouvoir public et dépo justement des
actions particulières dans le domaine du
sport
alors c'est une fondation qui a été
créée lorsque j'étais joueur de foot à
Barcelone très rapidement le club de
Barcelone m'a aidé a compris un petit
peu la démarche les joueurs de Barcelone
aussi ont prêté leur image tout au début
pour rendre publique cette fondation
mais l'idée est très simple c'est-à-dire
que en fait dire aux gens vous savez
nous sommes le fruit d'une histoire ch
de nous nous sommes conditionnés dans un
sens le racisme li à la couleur de la
peau et lié à une histoire de la
hiérarchisation des personnes selon leur
couleur de peau le sexisme et lié à une
histoire la hiérarchie entre les hommes
et les femmes l'homophobie aussi et lié
à une histoire et notamment lié à
l'histoire du conditionnement religieux
en fait de parler des choses
tranquillement c'est-à-dire que si nous
voulons parler du racisme il à la
couleur de la peau et comprendre
pourquoi effectivement euh la grande
majorité des joueurs qui se font
insulter dans les stades ce sont les
joueurs noirs c'est pas anodin c'est lié
à une histoire et si vous voulez euh
comprendre pourquoi tout le stade en
grande majorité accepte cela pourquoi la
société accepte cela parce qu'en fait
c'est culturel de mépriser les noirs et
si vous voulez savoir pourquoi c'est
culturel de mépriser les Noirs il faut
connaître le Code noir il faut connaître
le code de l'indigénat il faut savoir
que en France pendant plus de 250 ans il
y a eu des lois racistes en fait la
Fondation c'est emmené de la
connaissance pour qu'on puisse
comprendre ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
parce que la grande majorité des gens
lorsqu'ils parlent du racisme c'est
extrêmement superficiel ils sont
persuadés que ce sont des individus
après pourquoi ça perdure dans le temps
parce que effectivement euh moi je suis
un homme si le sexisme perdure dans le
temps bah les hommes ils ont des
responsabilités mais pourquoi ils vont
faire en sorte que les choses euh ne
changent pas parce qu'ils sont gagnants
dans ce système-là et le racisme c'est
exactement la même chose c'està-dire que
si les personnes noires sont
stigmatisées et violenté dans un stade
et que la grande majorité des personnes
qui regardent blanche en fait se sent
déconnecté ça veut dire que peut-être
que nous sommes encore dans ces
catégories lié à la couleur de la peau
et pourquoi nous sommes dans ces
catégories parce qu'encore une fois il y
a une histoire il y a une histoire qui
dit que il y aurait une catégorie
dominante et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'il faut questionner ces
catégories et en règle générale on ne
questionne pas ces catégories et donc
l'idée de la Fondation c'est vraiment
essayer ouais
d'emmener des informations pour qu'on
puisse réfléchir plus intelligemment et
surtout que on puisse prendre comprend
conscience que chacun de nous nous avons
des
préjugés chacun de nous nous portons en
nous des préjugés et qui fait que
parfois on fait comme si on ne savait
pas parce qu'encore une fois je pense
que tout le monde sait ce qui se passe
c'est-à-dire que comme dans le le
sexisme que ce soit les femmes que ce
soit les hommes nous savons ce qui se
passe et en fait moi c'est en fait la
Fondation c'est vraiment pour dire voilà
écoutez grandissons ensemble et arrêtons
de se
mentir arrêtons de se mentir et donc
effectivement je fais des choses dans
les écoles dans les universités un peu
partout dans le monde euh très rarement
dans le monde sportif parce qu'en fait
j'interviens lorsqu'on me demande de
venir je veux dire c'est pas moi qui je
me réveille pas un matin en disant tiens
je vais intervenir là en fait non il y a
des gens par exemple je vais très très
souvent en Suède parce que il y a une
université qui pense que ce travail là
est intéressant les livres sont traduits
aussi en suédois enfit je me je je me je
me déplace où on me demande par exemple
le lundi je vais partir une semaine en
Albanie mais parce que on m'a on m'a
invité en
B et quand vous dites très très peu
souvent dans le sport c'est parce que
vous n'êtes pas sollicité dans le sport
notamment je pense au sport français euh
oui complètement je suis pas sollicité
en fait c'est-à-dire que si si on me
demande de venir ce sera avec grand
plaisir mais encore une fois c'est
peut-être pas une priorité de de de
lutter contre le racisme de dénoncer le
racisme d'être éduqué pour faire avancer
les choses
juste avant de laisser la parole à
Madame la
rapporteur je voulais revenir aussi sur
un sujet que vous avez abordé là très
rapidement vous avez eu donc une
brillante carrière de football
international pendant près de deux
décennies
euh quels sont les faits de vous que
vous avez eu donc à votre connaissance
dans le champ de la commission d'enquête
à savoir les violences notamment donc
les tout types de violences les VSS en
particulier mais tout types de violence
vous avez parlé aussi de l'homophobie
rapidement tout à l'heure le racisme on
en parle mais à votre connaissance avez
eu avez-vous été à des moments
confrontés à ces
violences en fait très souvent
lorsque on parle de l'homophobie euh en
fait il y a les la les violences des
mots mais la grand la grande majorité
des gens euh n'ont pas conscience de
cela moi lorsque j'étais plus jeune euh
dans les vestiaires l'entraîneur à la
mi-temps du match si on jouait pas bien
bah il tenait des propos homophobes mais
si on lui disait euh c'est homophobe lui
il dirait bah non parce qu'en fait il y
a une question d'habitude vous avez pas
jouer comme des mais qu'est-ce
que vous voyez c'està dire que c'est
tellement ancré d'ailleurs moi quand
j'étais jeune joueur les supporters
pendant très longtemps lorsque le
gardien dégageait tenait des propos
homophobes qui ne tiennent plus
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont été éduqués
sensibilisés
et je reste persuadé que encore une fois
hein que beaucoup de personnes ne se
rendent pas compte de la la violence des
propos parce que ce sont c'est une
question d'habitude et pour eux en fait
on l'a toujours dit comme ça on a
toujours fait comme ça et c'est pour
cela que je je parle d'éducation mais
oui bien sûr qu'il y a eu des propos
homophobe comme sexiste mais encore une
fois le foot est à l'image de la société
le foot n'est qu'à l'image de la société
et donc effectivement vous si vous êtes
attentif c'està dire parce qu'il faut
être attentif
mais très souvent il y a des propos
racistes sexistes
homophobes merci beaucoup
euh moi je en fait on on rejoint parce
que on rejoint ce que vous avez dit
c'est-à-dire que nous on a plutôt le
sentiment que même si tout le monde euh
parle de d'atelier de d'information de
dispositifs sur la question du racisme
de l'homophobie ou des VSS on a plutôt
le sentiment que sur la question en tout
cas des faits racistes ou ou même
homophobe on n'a pas tellement évolué je
pense que on reviendra après sur le
match omol qui s'est déroulé il y a
quelques jours de cela et donc justement
on avait un président de de la
Fédération je vais parler de Monsieur
Noël logret qui déclarait dans la presse
quand un black marque un but tout le
stade est debout le phénomène raciste
dans le sport et dans le football en
particulier n'existe pas ou peu euh déjà
qu'est-ce que que vous ont inspiré ces
propos et puis peut-être aussi est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous pensez pas que
si déjà la tête d'une fédération telle
que la FFF on peut tenir ce genre de
propos comment est-ce qu'on peut avancer
sur la question du racisme quand desjens
on y même son
existence ben écoutez c'est c'est une
évidence
euh si tout en haut de l'échelle le
président qui doit mettre en place euh
des choses pour lutter contre le racisme
lui-même ni le racisme
bah c'est très
compliqué et c'est surtout que moi quand
quand j'entends ces choses-là pour moi
c'est du mépris en fait mais vraiment
c'est du mépris c'est-à-dire que c'est
vous êtes en train de nier ce que vivent
certaines personnes et lorsqu'on parle
du président de la Fédération française
c'est encore une fois euh des millions
euh de de de de personnes qui qui sont
touchées qui sont nié euh qui sont
violenté parce que c'est une violence
d'entendre quelqu'un dire qu'il n'y a
pas de racisme mais que ce soit le
président euh de la Fédération le
président de la République ou ou ou
n'importe qui c'est en fait c'est nier
ce que vous êtes en train de vivre ça
veut dire que quelque part les personnes
qui dénoncent le racisme ce sont des
menteurs mais là là encore ça revient à
une culture c'est-à-dire qu'en règle
générale les personnes qui dénoncent le
racisme finissent par être vu comme des
menteur et d'ailleurs moi-même par
exemple j'ai été éduqué à travers l'idée
que si tu subis le racisme c'est pas
grave tu dis rien et tu avances mais tu
dis rien tu avances pourquoi parce que
historiquement les parents ils savent
très bien que ça va se retourner contre
vous d'ailleurs moi-même au début quand
j'ai commencé à parler de la
problématique du racisme en fait il y
avait des gens qui me disaient ouais
mais ça va tu exagères ben non j'exagère
pas regardez ce qui s'est passé
dernièrement avec Bernard
Casoni donc il y a eu des joueurs qui
ont qui ont dit voilà qui tenaient des
propos
racistes mais lui il a porté plainte
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est des
menteurs les personnes qui disent qu'il
a tenu des propos racistes en fait et
c'est pour cela que c'est
extrêmement dangereux de nier le racisme
et venant de la Fédération française de
foot c'est juste surréaliste
c'est-à-dire que la première fois qu'il
y a eu un joueur noir en France ça date
pas de de de jours hein d'accord ça ça
je crois que c'est des les années 30
donc ça veut dire comment
vous vous pouvez nier le
racisme c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous
voyez la composition de l'équipe de
France comment vous pouvez mépriser ces
gens-là en fait c'est ça que parce que
pour pour moi c'est à quel point dans
notre société on peut mépriser les
personnes noires comment et pour moi
c'est c'est ça c'est dire dire oh mais
il y a pas de racisme bah si il y a du
racisme dans le foot mais encore une
fois pourquoi il y a du racisme dans le
foot parce que dans la société il y a du
racisme le problème c'est pas le foot
c'est la société et la première des
choses si on veut avancer c'est reconnaî
qu'il a du racisme et le fait de
reconnaître qu' est du racisme c'est
simplement dire aussi aux personnes qui
subissent le racisme en fait nous sommes
conscients de ce que vous vivez et vous
avez le droit de dénoncer le racisme et
ça c'est très important parce qu'encore
une fois les personnes qui
souffrent qui souffrent c'est une
violence et donc il faut aussi leur dire
vous avez le droit de dénoncer le
racisme vous avez le droit de vouloir
plus de justice et nous nous allons vous
accompagner parce que nous aussi nous
pensons que la justice est quelque chose
de primordial dans le football et dans
la
société je reste j'essaie d'être
calme c'est vous inquiétez pas on a des
auditions passionnées parfois ici donc
souvent d'ailleurs plus de notre côté
que du côté des des personnes
auditionnées ça nous change un peu
euh on a a été beaucoup aussi évoqué
donc les sanctions au moment où il y a
justement il y a des propos racistes qui
sont tenus dans le casadre du stade mais
aussi des propos homophobes dans
certains cas moi j'ai des exemples en
tête et d'ailleurs j'en avais cité un à
Monsieur Didier Deschamp qui a été
auditionné également sur des jets de
banane sur voilà et euh alors j'aurais
deux questions
euh la première c'est moi j'étais très
étonné mais peut-être vous pourrez m'en
dire un peu plus que monsieur deschan
nous disent que quasiment il avait
jamais été témoin euh de de de d'acte
raciste en tout cas dans le milieu du du
foot qu'il avait pas été témoin de de
ces phénomènes là alors que moi j'ai
juste tapé sur Google une fois et en
fait j'ai un match qui est sorti où il
était présent et et il y avait eu
justement ces fameux Jeet de banane et
la deuxième chose c'eston a reçu aussi
également ici l'association des
supporters euh qui sont totalement
opposés à l'idée de l'arrêt des matchs
par qu'il considèrent que c'est une
punition collective qu'il faut
travailler autrement moi j'aimerais
avoir votre avis justement là-dessus sur
euh quel sanction en fait euh quelle
sanction finalement au moment où il y a
euh des propos racistes qui sont tenus
ou homophobes d'autant plus que l'une
des difficultés qui a été évoquée aussi
dans le cadre de cette commission mais
on le comprend un peu aussi dans vos
propos c'est le fait que les victimes
qui subissent cette violence vous l'avez
dit à plusieurs reprise finalement elles
peuvent être sanctionnées vous vous
l'avez dit mais elles sont souvent
livrées à elles-mêmes en fait
c'est-à-dire qu'elles n'ont pas
d'accompagnement ne serait-ce que pour
porter plainte de vis-à-vis de ce
qu'elles subissent et qu'en fait de ce
point de vue-là ça c'est beaucoup revenu
aussi le non accompagnement finalement
des victimes dans le mouvement sportif
donc voilà nous on réfléchit aussi à
comment avancer sur ces questionsl et on
aimerait vous entendre
làdessus
alors pour moi c'est très important
l'éducation pourquoi l'éducation vous
permet de comprendre ce qui se passe
parce qu'en règle générale lorsque vous
ne subissez pas cette violence vous
pouvez ne pas vous vous en souvenir et
ne pas voir cette violence je dirais que
lorsque vous êtes un homme vous pouvez
ne pas prendre conscience que vous ne
vivez pas l'espace public comme les
femmes vivent l'espace public c'est une
éducation c'estàd qu'en fait il faut que
quelqu'un puisse vous éduquer à voir ce
que vous ne voyez pas mais le racis
c'est exactement la m chose c'est-à-dire
que moi je suis un homme noir j'ai 51
ans donc ça veut dire que j'ai vécu
certaines choses qui m'ont aussi
traumatisé c'està-dire que lorsque vous
avez 9 ans que vous arrivez dans la
région parisienne et que vous insulte de
salale noir mais vous commencez à vous
poser des questions en disant mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais si vous
n'avez jamais été confronté à ça
peut-être que si quelqu'un vous le
raconte sur le coup vous allez
l'entendre mais vous allez oublier par
exemple quand je vous dis que moi je me
souviens de Joseph Antoine belle mais
pourquoi je m'en souviens parce que Ben
quelque part Joseph Antoine Bell c'est
moi mais peut-être pour un enfant blanc
Joseph Antoine Bell c'est pas
lui et c'est comme quand on vous dit tu
as déjà subi le racisme dans le foot
ben lorsqu'on pose la question à à une
personne on s'attend que cette personne
parle d'elle-même mais à chaque fois
qu'il y a un problème de racisme dans le
foot ben en fait je suis touché en tant
que personne noire donc c'est pour cela
qu'en fait il y a parfois une certaine
incompréhension et c'est pour ça que moi
ça me ça me ça ne me surprend pas que
certaines personnes
oublient parce que effectivement ils
sont pas éduqués à avoir la gravité de
la situation je vous raconte lorsque
j'étais
joueur
très souvent à la fin du match on reste
à l'entraînement on s'étire et il y
avait toujours un coéquipier qui me
disait tu tu tu sais quoi avec tes
qualités physiques et mon intelligence
je serais trop
fort ok mais tout le monde n'est pas en
capacité de comprendre ce qui se joue
là d'accord et moi dans ma tête je me
disais mais
ok mais je relève pas d'accord parce que
de de nature je relève pas tout le temps
pour laisser la parole libre et pour
analyser les
choses en fait quand je dis que le
racisme c'est quelque chose de vraiment
culturel et où est-ce qu'il y a aussi un
problème c'est-à-dire que si vous dites
à quelqu'un tiens ses propos sont
racistes alors là c'est la panique
totale ouais comment tu peux dire ça je
suis pas raciste on lui a pas dit qu'il
était raciste on lui a dit que les
propos qu'il a tenu étaient racistes et
donc après on discute plus si vous
relevez trop S souvent vous finissez par
être le problème
ouais mais attendez vous parlez mais
c'est vous les racistes et donc en fait
si vous voulez moi pour moi c'est
vraiment ouais discuter de ces sujets
parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas que les
personnes qui subissent le racisme qui
devrait être violenté par ça au
contraire vous devrez être la la
première personne à accompagner celui
qui subit mais là aussi pour pagier il
faut comprendre la violence par exemple
à la Fondation très souvent nous sommes
invités par par des institutions et une
fois j'avais été invité il y avait des
saettes d'accord il faisait des scettes
toute la journée et moi je devais
regarder et faire une
analyse à la fin de la journée ce qui
était très intéressant dans toutes les
scettes lorsqu'il y avait un problème de
racisme en fait qu'est-ce qui se passait
les gens ils allaient vers celui qui
avait des propos racistes en disant non
ça tu peux pas dire c'est pas grave
c'est pas possible tu peux plus dire ça
franchement arrête parce que c'est pas
normal de de faire subir ça et je leur
disais mais vous avez vu toute la la
journée personne n'a été voir les
victimes pour dire j'ai vu ce qui se
passait et c'est pas normal ce qui se
passe et ben je seraai avec toi on va
aller voir les supérieurs pour dire que
l'attitude qu'il a eu n'est pas bonne
personne nallait aller voir les victimes
et c'est ce qui se passe au foot mais
aller voir les victimes c'est être
confronté au
racisme c'est ça le problème aller voir
les victimes de toute façon ça ça marche
avec toutes les victimes en règle
générale aller voir les victimes
discuter avec les victimes dire je suis
de ton côté c'est aussi dire que en fait
c'est vrai il y a du racisme et donc les
gens préfèrent faire comme ce que je
vous ai dit sur le terrain avec
l'arbitre éliminer le problème et on
continue et c'est ça qu'il faut changer
et pour changer il faut discuter il faut
débattre il faut éduquer les gens il
faut que les gens puissent comprendre
qu'effectivement ils ont un mauvais
comporté comportement face au racisme il
faut qu'ils comprennent qu'effectivement
c'est tout à fait légitime que les
personnes qui subissent des violences
euh ben puissent dénoncer ces violences
et lorsque vous êtes éduqué depuis
enfant à subir des propos racistes des
comportements raciste vous finissez par
croire savoir qu'en fait il faut rien
dire ça va se retourner contre vous
c'est pour ça que la grande majorité des
joueurs ne disent rien faites faites
bien faites analysez bien vous allez
voir que il y a quand même beaucoup de
joueurs qui potentiellement pourraient
subir le racisme donc potentiellement on
pourrait avoir beaucoup de joueurs qui
parlent de ces sujets très peu parlent
parce qu'en fait ils savent que de toute
façon ça peut se retourner contre eux et
la réalité que c'est très souvent ça se
retourne contre eux et moi je pense que
les fédérations les clubs devrait dire
au joueurs nous sommes de votre côté et
s'il y a un problème vous devait
absolument le
dire hier j'avais une réunion avec des
profess des jeunes
professeurs dans l'éducation nationale
et je leur disais c'est très important
que dans la classe s'il y a un problème
que les enfants sachent que le prof la
prof sera là et sera de bonne écoute si
vous savez qu'effectivement on va vous
écouter vous allez venir parler mais si
vous avez un doute vous n'allez pas
venir et au foot je pense que dans les
club encore une fois dans les
fédérations dans le monde professionnel
amateur il faudrait simplement dire aux
gens voilà nous sommes
là vous avez l'obligation de dénoncer
les actes de racisme et donc si vous
donnez
l'autorisation les matchs vont
s'arrêter les matchs vont s'arrêter mais
qui veut vraiment que les matchs
s'arrêtent parce que le foot c'est un
business attention hein ça veut dire que
qui veut vraiment que les matchs
s'arrêtent et si les matchs s'arrêtent
et les joueurs noirs décident
d'arrêter ça finit par que c'est eux les
problèmes comme je vous ai dit le carton
rouge c'est en fait ça n ça nous
intéresse pas vraiment en fait toi tu
sors parce qu'en fait effectivement on
t'insulte bon on va faire sans toi le
match va continuer parce que c'est ça la
réalité mais de la société avec le
racisme et c'est pour cela que je dis
attention si on veut comprendre cela il
faut juste questionner notre culture
et il y a une profondeur historique
effectivement qui dit toi on peut faire
sans toi tu as de la chance d'être où tu
es donc écoute commence pas à créer de
problème d'ailleurs ce qu'on dit à au
joueurs en règle général bah attendez ça
va ils sont bien payés puis c'est pas
bien grave ça va c'est juste pour c'est
juste pour déstabiliser c'est pas
vraiment du racisme et donc les
supporters qui veulent pas que le match
arrête
combien de supporters d'accord dans les
personnes que vous avez reçu là ont déjà
subi le
racisme que leurs
parents a subi du racisme que
potentiellement leurs enfants vont subir
le racisme parce que c'est ça la
question et peut-être qu'en fait la
vraie question c'est que peut-être
lorsque vous êtes une personne blanche
en fait qu'on arrête le match ou pas
c'est pas bien grave mais moi je reste
persuadé que si vous êtes à la
télévision et que vous êtes une famille
de personnes noires et que le match
sarrête vous êtes soulagé vous vous
dites enfin enfin le match s'arrête
parce qu'en fait c'est tout est une
question de point de vue où vous vous
placez et moi avec la Fondation je me
dis que peut-être que on peut se placer
en tant qu'être humain c'est-à-dire que
on peut effectivement être conscient de
la violence et de se dire que bah c'est
pas juste qu'il a cette violence c'est
pas juste que certaines personnes soient
violentées dans la société c'est pas
juste et donc il faut se poser la
question pourquoi la grande majorité des
gens en fait ça ne les intéresse pas et
ils ne le perçoivent pas moi je suis
assez je me dis qu'il ne le perçoivent
pas donc voilà pourquoi il faut les
éduquer
voilà juste pour revenir sur l'histoire
propos du vestiaire monsieur Marc
Savouret le réalisateur du film
documentaire je ne suis pas un singe le
racisme dans le football a estimé que
les entraîneurs et les dirigeants de
football noir ne représentaient que 5 %
des effectifs alors qu'il composeraient
50 % des effectifs de joueurs au vu de
votre carrière dans le monde du foot
pouvez-vous nous faire part de vos
commentaires sur cette
estimation pour autant j'ai j'ai regardé
le reportage donc je sais vous
paraît-elle juste s'expliquet-elle par
la persistance des pré raciste qui
voudrait que les joueurs noirs soient
athléti et puissant et les joueurs
blancs intelligents pour reprendre les
mots de Monsieur
savorel c'est vrai
qu'effectivement il faut toujours
essayer de de comprendre le pourquoi des
choses si jamais on vous dit
que pour vous c'est plus
compliqué même si vous travaillez vous
allez pas réussir
en fait la grande majorité des gens vont
se décourager et ne vont pas aller par
ce qui est normal si on vous dit que
vous pouvez réussir que vous avez toutes
vos chances ben vous allez y aller mais
la société envoie je veux dire c'est
c'est d' de l'inconscient hein envoie
des images des préjugés qui fait que
parfois les joueurs noir ne vont pas
passer le cap d'aller vers le fait de
passer les diplômes parce que de toute
façon il se dit mais en fait il y a pas
beaucoup de d'entraîneurs donc en fait
s'il y en a pas beaucoup bah peut-être
que je vais aller autre part et ça c'est
un tort c'est pour ça que je pas je dis
aussi qu'il faut éduquer que ce soit les
personnes qui subissent le racisme que
ce soit les personnes qui ne subissent
pas le racisme pour changer la façon de
voir les choses parce que tout est une
question souvent de penser
et hier aussi pareil j'en parla avec les
les
professeurs en fait il y a des messages
qui sont envoyés aux personnes noires
comme s'ils étaient pas CAPA d'aller
vers des travaux où on a besoin de
l'intellect c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
gens qui vous envoient des messages que
ce soit à l'école dans l'orientation
parfois parfois ça peut être même au
sein de votre propre famille c'est pour
cela que je dis que il faut discuter de
ces sujets parce que c'est une histoire
c'est culturel et donc c'est tout à fait
compréhensible qu'effectivement bah qui
est moins d'entraîneurs parce que je
pense que déjà il y en a moins il y a
pas beaucoup d'entraîneurs qui noirs qui
vont aussi aller
vers
les j'allais dire les études pour faire
pour devenir entraîneur mais ce qui est
si aussi intéressant dans dans l'analyse
c'estàdire si on peut
analyser je ne dis pas que c'est du
racisme je dis qu'il faut analyser les
choses en règle générale
vous allez voir que pour comprendre le
le sexisme en fait il faut
analyser vous prenez un échantillon vous
regardez tout en bas et vous regardez
tout en haut plus vous allez aller dans
des postes de responsabilité plus il y
aura des hommes c'est comme ça ça veut
dire que dans les sociétés mais par
contre vous allez descendre l'échelle
vous allez voir qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes mais le racist à la
couleur de la peau c'est exactement la
même chose si si vous allez regarder
dans la région parisienne les
entraîneurs qui entraînent les enfants à
bas niveau vous allez voir qu'il y aura
beaucoup de joueurs noirs et de de
joueurs de il y aura beaucoup
d'entraîneurs noirs et des entraîneurs
di
magrébin plus vous allez monter moins il
y en aura ok c'est une analyse
c'est-à-dire que je ne suis pas en train
de dire que c'est basé sur le racisme en
fait c'est une analyse et il faut juste
essayer de comprendre les choses parce
que que parfois aussi lorsque vous
dénoncez le racisme dans la société que
vous essayez de l'expliquer on va
toujours essayer de transformer vos
propos pour dire que vous voyez tout à
travers le fait qu'il est du racisme moi
c'est pas ce que je dis je dis
simplement que le racisme est culturel
et que nous reproduisons des schémas et
qu'il faut prendre conscience de ces
schémas là voilà parce que quand le
joueur en question il me dit avec ton
physique et mon
intelligence ben tout est dit
hein et beaucoup de personnes le pensent
encore je vais vous donner un une
anecdote qui concerne ma propre famille
moi depuis que j'ai mes enfants je parle
tranquillement sereinement du racisme et
j'essaie de les vacciner pour que en
fait lorsqu'ils sont confrontés au
racisme ça ne blesse pas la chose la
plus importante l'estime de soi qui
finissent pas par croire certaines
choses un jour mon fils Marcus rentre
euh de l'école il me dit papa j'ai un
copain qui m'a dit que les mathématiques
étaient plus dur pour moi je dis ah bon
il je dis pourquoi mais parce que je
suis noir je dis bon ah bon qu'est-ce
que tu as fait bah j'ai rigolé ok mais
lui il a rigolé pourquoi parce qu'en
fait j'avais déjà anticipé le problème
en leur disant faites très attention
vous allez grandir vous allez voir qu'il
y a des gens qui vont mettre en doute V
Capacité notamment intellectuelle parce
que vous êtes noir ets vont survaloriser
vos capacités athlétiques parce que vous
êtes noir mais n'oubliez pas que c'est
ces personnes-là qui ont un problème
donc comme ils ont été éduqués par moi
donc en fait quand ils entendent ces
choses-là ils peuvent les analyser ils
peuvent rigoler mais vous voyez bien que
c'est quelque chose qui circule dans
l'espace public cette
idée-là mais encore une fois c'est le
fruit de l'histoire et donc il faut
analyser l'histoire expliquer les choses
pour que les gens puissent avoir un
regard sur eux-mêmes pour ne pas
reproduire ces schémas
voilà une question de notre collègue
Stéphane
Buchou merci madame la Présidente
bonjour monsieur turam Stéphane Buchou
député de vandé vice-président de la
Commission à vous
écouter on entend
que le racisme le problème du racisme
c'est culturel
dit autrement enfin moi je dis autrement
c'est un mal très profond qui qu'il est
complexe de de de de
d'éradiquer j'emploie souvent ce termel
euh moi je partage he tout ce que vous
avez dit sur l'éducation l'échange la
discussion avec avec les uns et et avec
les autres
euh je pense malheureusement que ce
n'est pas suffisant et moi je crois
beaucoup à je crois beaucoup à forme de
choc
et je reviens j'en ai déjà parlé ce
matin à une audition que nous avons eu
hier après-midi sur le sujet de
l'homophobie avec une association qui
s'appelle je sais plus rouge dir rouge
direct voilà
et de
l'implication des joueurs professionnels
médiatiques et donc de leur de leur
capacité à s'engager contre le racisme
et et de s'engager de manière forte et
j'en reviens à l'arrêt des
matchs pour ne citer qu'un exemple et
c'est celui qui a été cité a été cité
hier et c'était c'était sorte de cri du
cœur de la part de des membres de
l'association qui qui était de dire mais
si un Kyan Mbappé lorsqu'il est sur le
terrain et qu'il entend des champs
homophobes homophobes
pardon disait moi j'arrête arrête de
jouer dans ces
conditions nous on pense que la cause
évidemment elle serait différente et
elle avancerait et moi c'est ça que j'ai
envie de de c'est là-dessus que j'ai
envie de vous vous entendre même si vous
en avez un peu parlé mais de vous
entendre peut-être plus plus
concrètement vous avez une longue
carrière et une brillante carrière de
footballeur vos deux fils sont en train
de marcher sur sur vos pas il y avait du
racisme avant
lilianturam il y a du racisme
après Lilian turam avec Marcus avec
kfren et tous les
autres qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'ils
peuvent faire qu'est-ce qu'il est-ce
que-ce vous le nous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous les aviez éduqué pour
qu'ils en
rigolent est-ce que pardon j'ai pas de
leçon d'éducation à vous donner c'est
pas du tout mon propos mais est-ce que
c'est ça la solution ou ou est-ce qu'à
un moment donné t tous ces joueurs là
qui sont adulés
entendant dans ces champs qui soient
homophobe racistes dans les stades ne
peuvent pas dire STOP est-ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure moi je suis un fan
de football le football c'est du
business ouais c'est du business mais
est-ce qu' a un moment donné
l'engagement il est pas aussi
l'exemplarité elle est pas aussi de dire
stop
maintenant alors tout
d'abord si une personne
noire arrive à rigoler en face de propos
raciste en n'ayant pas de doute que
c'est que c'est celui qui tient les
propos racistes qui a un problème c'est
vous avez tout gagné croyez-moi parce
qu'en règle générale lorsque vous êtes
enfant qu'on vous
insulte vous finissez par croire que
vous avez un problème et si vous
finissez par croire que vous avez un
problème vous allez grandir
différemment donc voilà pourquoi aussi
il faut éduquer les personnes qui
subissent le racisme et encore une fois
c'est tout type de victime hein à partir
du moment où vous avez la la conscience
que celui qui vous agresse a un problème
je pense que c'est fondamental pour bien
grandir après ce qui est très
intéressant moi j'aiété joueur de foot
d'accord moi j'essaie de dire aux
joueurs qu'il faut s'éduquer à
comprendre les choses ce qui se passe à
parler à dire les
choses mais je trouve d'une grande
hypocrisie quand même si je peux me
permettre de penser qu'en fait que c'est
les joueurs qui ont la
solution c'est-à-dire que c'est trop
facile d'aller dire que en fait cette
société là qui produit de l'homophobie
qui accepte l'homophobie et en fait de
dire aux joueurs que c'est vous qui avez
les clés c'est-à-dire que ceux avant qui
ont les clés c'est peut-être les
présidents de club c'est peut-être
peut-être la
télévision d'accord qui finance le foot
ça veut dire qu'avant d'arriver au au
joueurs de foot il y a des acteurs
beaucoup plus
importants c'est-à-dire que peut-être
qu'avant que les joueur il y a peut-être
l'arbitre parce que c'est lui le chef
sur le terrain et donc peut-être que il
faut insister en disant aux arbitres
mais pourquoi vous laissez le match
continuer
pourquoi mais peut-être que en fait
encore une fois comme j'ai été joueur de
foot peut-être
que
inconsciemment ben je me dis que ok moi
je veux bien participer à changer les
mentalités mais ne me faites pas croire
qu'en fait que c'est de ma faute si ça
continue vous vous comprenez ce que je
dire c'est-à-dire que je suis le premier
encore une fois depuis que je suis
joueur de foot à un moment donné je
disais même dans les en Italie souvent
je disais mais attendez mais je je
comprends pas pourquoi les joueurs
blancs ne s'arrêtent pas pourquoi on
demande toujours au joueurs noirs
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire parce qu'en
fait à un moment donné c'était monsieur
turam il faut continuer à jouer il faut
vous arrêter qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
et moi je leur disais mais attendez
excusez-moi en fait vous pensez que
c'est moi qui va résoudre le problème
mais la grande majorité des joueurs
blancs mais c'est à eux qu'il faut aller
demander pourquoi ils ne disent rien
pourquoi ils continuent à jouer vous
voyez ce que je veux dire j'essayais
d'in c'est le truc pour que un moment
donné que la responsabilité du
changement vous ne fassiez ne pas croire
que en fait bah c'est moi qui trouve la
solution non c'est pas moi qui va
trouver la solution et les joueurs de
foot ben c'est pareil bien sûr qu'il
faut les éduquer mais il faut commencer
à aller voir les présidents de club et
leur dire mais comment se
fait-il il faut aller voir la Fédération
il faut avoir voir les les arbitres
parce que très souv souvent quand il se
passe un problème de racisme on pose des
questions aux arbitres aux dirigeants
ils n'ont jamais
entendu ils entendent pas et donc eux
n'entendent pas les joueurs de foot qui
sont dans une concentration totale et
qui courent eux devraient entendre et
c'est eux qui devraient faire quelque
chose et donc c'est pour ça que encore
une fois je dis que il faut éduquer les
joueurs à analyser les choses à
intervenir mais par contre leur mettre
la
responsabilité en faisant croire que ils
ont le
pouvoir de arrêter le
match je pense que il y a d'autres
acteurs avant qu'on doit aussi leur
demander pourquoi vous n'intervenez pas
pourquoi vous ne faites pas les
choses peut-être que je pas bien compris
hein votre
analyse je pense que vous l'avez très
bien compris The
et non c'est intéressant c'est c'est
très intéressant ce que ce que vous
dites je je moi j'entends hein j'entend
en tous les cas le
l'aspect
multi multi-outil c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
pas il y a on ne va pas cibler que que
les joueurs al c'était pas c'était pas
le sens de mon intervention euh
évidemment qu'il y a d'autres acteurs
vous les avez
oui mais vous les avez cité les arbitres
les les présidents de les présidents de
club et cetera et
cetera mais votre vos propos votre votre
témoignage il est il est aussi
l'illustration et et n'y voyez aucune
aucun reproche dans mes propos mais il
est aussi l'illustration de ce qu'on a
beaucoup entendu et qu'on continue en
fait à à entendre lors de ces auditions
c'est-à-dire que l'objet de cette
l'objet de cette commission d'enquête
c'est c'est l'après
c'est aujourd'hui on a énormément de
témoignages contre les enfin sur ce qui
a pu se passer en terme de
VSS homophobie racisme et cetera et
cetera et c'est comment est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on fait mieux comment
est-ce qu'on on parvient collectivement
à ce que
c'est c'est situation soit éliminé et en
fait très
souvent on nous
renvoi un peu sur ce que vous dites
c'est-à-dire
que il faut aller voir il faut il faut
aller voir d'autres d'autres acteurs
parce que nous on veut pas être les les
victimes non non mais et juste en tous
les cas moi j'entends ça j'entends ça je
pense qu'il y a aussi un un aspect
générationnel on l'a vu aussi dans la
gouvernance des fédérations où où où il
y a pas cette cette sensibilité et je
pense que ça
aussi ça ça c'est à l'origine de de pas
mal de de problèmes en revanche je je en
tous les cas moi ça ce qui a été dit
hier après-midi m'a m'a marqué parce que
je pense néanmoins que les joueurs de
football en particulier parce que c'est
le football et parce que parce que voilà
c'est le sport numéro 1 ont
effectivement euh une une responsabilité
il s'agit pas de leur faire tout leur
faire porter sur leurs épaules mais je
pense que oui si à un moment donné parce
que trop c'est trop il s'arrêtait je je
j'entends que c'est une très très lourde
responsabilité avec tous les enjeux
médiatiques financiers et cetera j'ai
parfaitement conscience de tout ça mais
c'est pour ça que je parle de choc et je
crois que si on veut vraiment que ça
avance en parallèle de l'éducation et de
tout ce que vous avez dit et que je
rejoins à 200 %
euh pour moi c'est un un élément un
élément extrêmement important en terme
d'image et en terme de responsabilité
alors encore une fois je vous dis juste
juste je vous interromps je me permets
madame la rapporteur vous veut compléter
la
question juste peut-être voilà avant de
qu'on vous laisse la
parole moi ce que je veux vous dire en
fait et ce qu'on veut partager avec vous
c'est que depuis le début de cette
commission d'enquête que ce soit sur les
agressions sexuelles
l'effet de racisme d'homophobie et
compris d'ailleurs parfois de
gouvernance financière et de ce qui se
passe dans ce mouvement sportif d'abord
régulièrement quand on a interrogé des
personnes on nous a dit c'est pas moi
c'est l'autre ça c'est systématique on a
eu le cas d'ailleurs pas plus tard que
ce matin on avait reçu Monsieur Borgini
on a reçu madame Ardoin on a reçu Noël
lerette on a reçu Monsieur la Perre et
en fait personne n'est responsable voilà
sur les quatre personnes qui étaient là
pourtant ils ont tous des
responsabilités à des niveau très
différents et on se rend compte que tout
le monde se se renvoie la balle en
disant c'est pas moi euh on a confié
cette responsabilité à quelqu'un c'est
cette personne-là qui devait s'en
occuper donc ça c'est le premier élément
ce qui fait que nous euh on essaie
d'identifier là où il y a des
dysfonctionnements justement pour y
apporter des réponses très précises la
deuxième chose c'est que moi je trouve
intéressant y compris dans dans ce que
disait mon collègue c'est que en fait
nous ce qu'on essaie de dire et je enfin
j'espère ne pas traduire ta pensée c'est
que euh il y a une responsabilité bien
sûr des arbitres et des responsables de
ligue et des responsables euh de
fédération et de clubs y compris
d'ailleurs il y a une responsabilité de
l'État parce qu'on on n' pas évoqué le
ministère de tutelle ici mais il y a une
responsabilité de l'État et quand on
voit ce qui s'est passé dans le match OM
OL entendre le ministre de l'Intérieur
dire qu'il n'est pas responsable de la
sécurisation des choses je sais plus
exactement quelle expression il a tenu
c'est un problème aussi en fait on peut
pas tous collectivement se défausser et
se dire ce n'est pas nous et peut-être
la petite subtilité c'est que je pense
que il y les joueurs de foot
particulièrement parce que c'est celui
qui est le plus il y a 2 millions de
licenciés c'est le rêve de toute de
plein d'enfants en réalité de devenir un
jour sportif de haut niveau ces joueurs
de foot là représentent pour toute une
partie de la jeunesse un modèle et en
fait le fait que par exemple un joueur
de foot qui décide parce qu' hier c'est
l'exemple qui a été cité si demain
Kilian Mbappé c'est l'association rouge
direct qui l'a cité en disant j'arrête
parce queil y a des propos homophobes
dans le stade pour nous c'est pas la
question de faire peser la
responsabilité de l'arrêt du match même
si je comprend votre position mais c'est
de dire à un moment Mbappé c'est le
modèle de millions de jeunes de millions
de jeunes est-ce que le fait que lui
disent mais en fait l'homophobie ça
suffit ça ne peut plus durer sur un
stade et bien ça aussi ça peut être un
un choc pour toute une génération qui
peut comprendre et qui peut entendre que
bah oui en fait les propos homophobes
sont pas
acceptables mais pour arriver à ça
d'accord il faudrait que les joueurs
soient conscient que en fait tout le
monde est d'accord avec ça parce que
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure le
joueur qui se plaint d'accord le joueur
noir qui dit oh il y a un problème
d'accord il y a un problème ça veut dire
qu'en fait il faut arrêter il y a un
problème il prend carton rouge mais
c'est pas c'est pas une fois deux fois
ou trois fois alleer analyser quand il y
a un problème vous allez voir que il
sort du terrain en règle générale ou
même parfois il veut arrêter de jouer
ses coéquipiers vont le chercher les
adversaires vont le chercher pour que le
match
continue parce que c'est ça la réalité
de comment le nous sommes éduqués c'est
en fait d'accepter les choses donc c'est
pour cela que je comprends ce que vous
dites moi je suis le premier à à dire
aux joueurs qu'il faut éduquer qu'il
faut dire les choses d'accord dire les
les choses ne pas accepter les choses
mais la réalité c'est qu'en fait vous
vous pensez que les joueurs en fait sont
dans une éducation
et qui ne savent pas ce qui va se passer
à ce moment-là déjà premièrement s'il y
a que Kilien Mbappé ça va pas
marcher d'accord ça veut dire qu'on va
l'app en dire non mais vas-y non mais
attends on va aller dans t'inquiète pas
on va arranger ça parce que c'est comme
ça que ça c'est toujours comme ça quand
vous êtes sur le terrain parce que il
faut être sur le terrain c'està-dire que
au départ vous êtes là c'est c'est ça
qui qui m'interpelle c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes sur le terrain vous êtes
concentré en règle
générale le le vous n'entendez pas
vraiment ce qui se passe dans le stade
parce que il y a une concentration
totale et donc c'est le joueur qui
devrait
entendre alors que lui il est concentré
totalement alors que que tout autour du
terrain il y a des personnes qui
pourraient totalement intervenir et
légitimement
intervenir qui sont garant du
spectacle je comprends ce que vous dites
attention hein je comprends totalement
ce que je vous dis je dis simplement
qu'effectivement peut-être que le fait
de dire tout
simplement Kilian Mbappé en fait c'est
comment je pourrais dire
ça
c'est juste pour vous dire qu'en fait ça
va pas se passer c'est juste pour vous
dire ça en fait ça ça va pas se passer
ça veut dire que il faut éduquer les
joueurs et pour éduquer les joueurs
d'accord il faut que les joueurs a
conscience que en fait il participe tout
un tout un mouvement parce que le J il
peut vous
dire pourquoi en fait moi tout le monde
entend là les présidents tout le monde
et vous me dites à moi de d'arrêter le
match
oui mais oui mais il faut que quelqu'un
accepte c'est pour ça que je parle
d'éducation moi je suis persuadé que si
dès les centres de formation d'accord on
éduque les jeunes en leur disant voilà
quand vous jouez il y a des choses
inacceptables vous avez le droit de
faire en sorte d'arrêter et donc vous
allez avoir toute une génération de
joueurs éduqués dans un sens mais là il
sont pas éduqués dans ce sens-là
hein les joueurs aujourd'hui ne sont pas
éduqués dans ce
sens-là d'ailleurs comme tout le monde
c'est-à-dire tout le monde est éduqué
dans un sens il faut que les choses
continuent parce que c'est le plus
important la meilleure façon de lutter
contre ces gens-là parfois on vous dit
c'est de les ignorer moi je suis
d'accord avec vous il faut pas les
ignorer mais moi je vous dis
qu'effectivement bien évidemment mais ne
renvoyez pas la responsabilité
non mais
oui c'est de dire voilà il faut éduquer
Kilien Mbappé à dénoncer l'homophobie à
participer à des choses comme les
joueurs peuvent le faire mais la
responsabilité de l'arrêt du match ne
peut pas être la responsabilité d'un
joueur
ah peut-être juste pour vous préciser ce
qu'a dit le ministre de l'Intérieur pour
qu'on pour qu'on soit tous au même
niveau donc par rapport au match omol il
a dit hier il y avait des motards des
policiers des CRS qui encadraient des
carts et qui encadraient des bus de
joueurs de supporters ce n'est déjà pas
très normal dans un monde classique euh
des gens ont jeté des canettes de bière
sur les vitres d'un bus est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est la responsabilité des
policiers non c'est la responsabilité de
celui qui jette la canette ce sont les
propos du ministre suite au match omol
je je le je le précisais par rapport à
ce que je disais tout à l'heure et
justement peut-être pour revenir sur ce
sur ce ce match en particulier euh
le l'ancien président de de l'OL a
réclamé à la à la LFP des sanctions
exemplaires dont l'annulation définitive
du du match et on a beaucoup parlé voilà
de de l'arrêt des matchs et et je vous
ai dit les associations ici en tout cas
de supporters nous ont dit que pour eux
CIT des sanctions collectives euh et
normalement il y a des graduations qui
sont prévues dans les sanctions mais
jusqu'à présent je crois mais peut-être
que vous pourrez nous éc là-dessus j'ai
pas vu en tout cas d'affair où des
personnes ont été euh poursuivies et
condamné euh pour des propos qu'ils
auraient tenu dans l'enceinte d'un stade
de fait raciste ou homophobe euh et
pareil je vous pose la question parce
que on a beaucoup parlé de l'Angleterre
en terme d'exemple sur l'interdiction à
vie des States par exemple pour certains
supporters dans ce match là en
particulier les supporterurs de l'OL qui
étaient des ultras identifiés pour
certains d'entre eux avaient
interdiction euh d'aller sur un stade à
Lyon mais pas d'interdiction sur
Marseille voilà est-ce que de ce point
de vue-là parce que c'est une
interdiction de billetterie sur Lyon et
pas forcément partout sur le territoire
donc voilà est-ce que de ce point de
vue-là il y aurait des évolutions par
exemple est-ce que vous serriez
favorable à ce que des supporters qui
sont reconnus identifiés comme étant des
personnes qui ont des propos racistes
homophobes au sein d'une enceinte
sportif parce que vous beaucoup ont dit
d'ailleurs le sport n'est que le le
reflet de la société de ce qui passe
mais d'autres ici nous ont dit on a le
sentiment que dans le sport c'est plus
permissif parce que finalement des
propos homophobe ou raciste dans à
l'extérieur d'un stade serait plus
facilement condamné ou condamnable que
ce qui se passerait à l'intérieur d'un
stade ça par exemple peut-être votre
avis là-dessus et sur l'interdiction
définitive par exemple des des
supporters qui pose problème comme en
Angleterre bah écoutez alors il faut
savoir déjà que
en dehors du stade lorsque vous subissez
par exemple racisme il faut savoir que
la grande majorité des gens ne vont pas
porter plainte ah ben bien sûr que c'est
un problème mais c'est un problème mais
pourquoi les gens ne portent pas plainte
parce que dans leur imaginaire ben ça va
servir à
rien ben encore une fois j'ai c'est
c'est c'est l'histoire que je peux vous
raconter c'est-à-dire que vous dénoncez
le racisme on finit par vous dire que
vous avez un problème et que ça s'est
pas passé ça veut dire que vous mentez
donc les gens n'y vont pas pour ça après
moi bien évidemment que je suis assez
d'accord que si il y a des personnes qui
tiennent des propos et on sait qu'il
vont tenir des propos il faut les bannir
du stade pour moi c'est une évidence
d'ailleurs je savais pas que vous
pouviez être banni à Lyon mais par
contre vous pouviez aller prendre des
billets à Marseille ça me paraît
bizarreation bah ouais ça moi ça me
paraît bizarre mais de toute façon dans
la société lorsqu'il y a des personnes
qui posent problème bah en fait il y a
une justice qui essaie de faire en sorte
de
de de de résoudre de résoudre le
problème et dans le stade c'est encore
plus facile d'ailleurs dans les stades
parce que quand même il y a un nombre
bien déterminé on sait qui est qui et
effectivement je pense qu'à partir du
moment où vous avez un mauvais
comportement dans un stade normalement
on pourrait vous interdire l'entrée des
stades mais pas simplement un stade ou
deux c'est-à-dire que si vous avez un
mauvais comportement ben euh vous ne
pouvez pas jouer dans dans enfin vous ne
pouvez pas aller regarder les matchs peu
importe le stade où c'est enfin ça me
paraît vous êtes sûr de ça c'est vrai
alors ah ah excusez-moi nous ce qu'on a
compris euh et d'ailleurs c'est
l'explication qu'on nous a donné c'est
que il y a des interdictions
administratives et de billetterie donc
qui sont en lien avec la Ligue et donc
c'était le cas à Lyon mais c'est pas
quelque chose de juridique en fait enfin
de judiciaire donc en fait il y avait
pas de décision ou de condamnation de
ces supporters pour leur interdire
l'accès à tous les stades c'est
l'explication qu'on nous a donné nous
aussi on a posé la question et on
voudrait comprendre justement comment ça
fonctionne parce que l'intérêt c'est ce
qu'on essaie de sur ça fait partie des
choses sur lesquelles on souhaite
avancer c'est de se dire qu'à un moment
si on a une interdiction sur un stade
pour des propos tels que ça a été le cas
parce que là on a eu des saluts naziis
on a eu des des personnes qui ont montré
leur passeport à d'autres joueurs en
disant bah nous on est français pas vous
et cetera mais en fait la logique
voudrait qu'il n'ait pas accès à aucun
stade en fait qu'il n'ait pas d'accès
mais là visiblement c'était le
cas
bah qu'est-ce que je peux vous dire
normalement normalement si on vous
interdit de rentrer dans un stade pour
moi c'est dans tous les stades surtout
si vous on sait que vous avez des
comportements euh
ben franchement c'est difficile à
répondre
là juste peut-être pour vous confirmer
parce qu'on est sur le code du sport
donc en fait c'est possible donc en fait
on peut vous interdire juste certains
matchs euh juste voilà c'est on n'est
pas obligé de vous interdire l'accès à
tous les stades et à tous les matchs
c'est tout à fait possible dépend ça
dépend de quoi de la gravité de ce que
vous avez pu faire c'est ça en
fait pour Lyon c'était des ultras et des
identifiés qui avait une interdiction
sur sur ça donc en fait voilà et ils
avaient autorisation à Marseille non
mais de toute façon je pense que les
chos évoluent donc ça veut dire qu'après
après ce qui s'est passé ben la loi va
évoluer
peut-être c'est alors c'est l'objectif
de la commission justement c'est pour ça
qu'on pointe aussi les
voil disc entre nous il y a les on à
l'extérieur du stade donc sur les sur
les bus et qui ont blessé d'ailleurs
gravement l'entraîneur de Lyon mais il y
a aussi tout ce qui a été tenu à
l'intérieur de l'enceinte du stade dont
les salut nazis et les champs homophobes
d'ailleurs des supporters marseillais
qui ont conduit à l'arrêt du match ce
dimanche soir
là moi je pense que effectivement à
partir du moment il y a des gens qui
rentrent dans un St s'il y a des
personnes qui ne se comportent pas bien
effectivement il faut leur interdire
l'entrée des stades et s'ils se
comportent pas bien je sais pas moi à
newor ils peuvent pas aller à guingan
voilà ça ça sympa
ouais
voilà c'est peut-être pas le hasard il
faut pas qu'il aille voilà donc en fait
oui ouii moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ça je pense que tout le
monde est d'accord avec ça
d'ailleurs une question de Madame Pascal
Martin bonjour Monsieur turam Pascal
Martin député de la Dordogne alors je ne
suis pas du tout une spécialiste du
monde du football mais je suis plutôt
mais si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est que
je m'intéresse à ce qui se passe dans ce
milieu et que j'ai autour de moi des
gens qui s'y intéressent et qui qui
m'éduque justement euh et je vous écoute
depuis tout à l'heure et et moi je suis
plutôt
disons que j'ai de bonnes connaissances
autour des questions du du sexisme et je
vous écoute depuis tout à l'heure et
d'ailleurs vous y avez fait référence il
y a énormément de de parallèles
possibles entre le racisme l'homophobie
le sexisme et et tout à l'heure vous
vous nous avez dit il faut éduquer bien
sûr il faut
sensibiliser il y a aussi la question de
l'identification et voilà je suis une
femme donc effectivement je me suis
intéressée depuis de long longes années
à ce que ça représentait ces inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes vous êtes
une personne de couleur noire et donc
vous avez subi le racisme depuis que
vous êtes enfant et les personnes que
nous avons entendu hier effectivement de
rouge direct ou même monsieur housoussem
Belkassem que nous avons reçu hier à
l'Assemblée nationale nous expliquer
aussi combien il peut être difficile de
parler et et c'est là où je vais en
venir vous avez dit c'est parfois
difficile et on renonce à porter plainte
vous avez suivi sans doute comme moi en
tant que citoyen tout ce qui s'est passé
autour de la libération de la parole
pour les femmes et je pense que même si
ça peut être difficile je voulais avoir
un échange avec vous à ce sujet parce
que c'est dans l'échange vous l'aveaz
dit qu'on peut progresser
ensemble je pense que cette libération
de la parole elle a aussi permis de
commencer un peu à mon goût pas assez
vite mais tout comme sans doute sur les
questions de racis
elle a aussi permis de faire en sorte
que la société euh se sente moins libre
de tous ses propos et de tous ces
agissements sexistes malgré tout il en
reste il y a encore beaucoup de travail
à faire vous l'avez souligné il y a
toute une histoire aussi qui qui entoure
ces questionsl et moi je suis attachée
au
triptique dont on parle quand on parle
des questions d'agression sexuelle c'est
je te crois on va t'aider la loi te
protège et je pense que quand on a aussi
à subir le racisme il faudrait qu'on
puisse arriver à sensibiliser dans ce
sens c'està dire à ce que chaque
personne pense que réellement elle est
cru quand elle parle parce que c'est
aussi ça le problème c'est que des fois
quand on parle on n'est pas cru que en
plus on n pas forcément le sentiment que
la loi protège la loi elle est là pour
les les actees racises tout comme pour
les les actes sexistes mais malgré tout
la justice ne suit pas forcément et puis
on n' pas forcément le sentiment qu'on
va être aidé aussi puisque il y a pas
force les instances n'existent pas ou
elles existent mal et il me semble
depuis que j'entends là les témoignages
autour de la
FFF que enfin je sais pas je suis très
surprise j'entends les gens qui nous
disent mais il y a des chartes il y a
des belles intentions enfin je je le
transforme comme ça il y a des belles
intentions encore ce matin on nous dit
mais il y a il y a il y a tout ce qu'il
faut pour que ça change et ça ne change
pas donc il y a bien un problème et
peut-être que le problème il est aussi
autour de alors l'éducation des l'école
effectivement en tant que parents en
tant que membre d'une famille moi je
suis grand-mère j'ai des petits enfants
qui jouent au foot je m'intéresse aussi
à ce qui se passe dans leur petit club
de foot en région euh voilà ces
instances là qui existent d'après les
dirigeants de la FFF euh elles existent
mais visiblement elles arrivent pas à
faire changer les choses donc il y a
bien un moment donné il y a un endroit
où ça gripe quoi donc est-ce que c'est
juste une image de façade j'aimerais
avoir votre avis là-dessus parce que
vous nous dites aussi que vous
intervenez plutôt à l'étranger que ici
visiblement le ministère des sports ou
les clubs de foot s'intéresse pas
malheureusement je dirais au travail de
votre fondation donc où est-ce que ça
gripe pourquoi ça gripe alors j'ai ma
petite réponse à moi c'est que il y a
beaucoup trop d'argent dans ce milieu et
que peut-être c'est ça aussi qui grippe
les choses mais voilà votre avis
là-dessus pourquoi d'un côté on nous dit
il y a tout ce qu'il faut pour prévenir
l'homophobie le racisme le sexisme et
que en la réalité c'est qu'il y a encore
des gens vous l'avez dit qui ne parlent
pas juste pour aller dans le sens de ma
collègue quand on a auditionné monsieur
lerette il nous a indiqué qu'il y avait
eu 3 millions d'euros qui avaient été
fléché pour la lutte contre l'homophobie
et euh de la vie de toutes les assut je
crois qu'on a auditionné ont dit qu' ça
avait pas changé grand-chose donc il y a
beaucoup d'argent visiblement il y a des
outils alors on a compris qu'il y avait
pas forcément de volonté jusqu'à présent
d'avancer donc où est le problème dans
tout ça enfin voilà pourquoi ça
fonctionne
pas c'est compliqué à répondre quand
même bon déjà déjà si vous êtes
président et vous donnez 3 millions et
vous-même vous dites qu'il y a pas de
racisme déjà là il y a une ambig
non mais c'est
vrai mais encore une
fois si on pense et moi je le pense
aussi sincèrement que les joueurs de
foot peuvent avoir un rôle clé notamment
les joueurs professionnels puisqueen
fait c'est eux qui sont suivis mais pour
cela il faut qu'ils comprennent qu'il
soi éduqués moi je prends mon exemple
c'est-à-dire que si je suis devant vous
à parler de ces sujets c'est que je me
suis éduqué j'ai fini par comprendre
effectivement en étant joueur de foot
j'ai une parole qui va aller beaucoup
plus loin ça veut dire que je veux me
servir de ma notoriété pour pouvoir
faire passer un message mais pour cela
il faut que les joueurs soient éduqués
dans ce sens-là et donc c'est pour cela
que je dis que que ce soit dans les
clubs dans les fédérations
professionnelles amateur il faut pouvoir
sensibiliser très tôt les jeunes par
exemple on parle de
l'homophobie qu'est-ce que les joueurs
connaissent de
l'homophobie bah parce que c'est ça
aussi le problème qu'est-ce qu'ils
connaissent du racisme du sexisme ça
veut dire qu'on va leur dire de
participer à certaines choses peut-être
qu'ils vont y participer mais en fait
qu'il ne comprennent pas totalement le
sujet et si ils comprennent totalement
le sujet peut-être qu'il aura 3 4 5 6
parce que ça suffit il suffit pas euh de
beaucoup hein on n pas de sensibiliser
la grande majorité non il suffit de
sensibiliser et que quelques joueurs en
fait le ressent
profondément profondément par exemple il
y a beaucoup de joueurs qui ne font pas
le lien entre racisme lié à la couleur
de la peau et homophobie
ou sexisme parce que en fait ça a rien à
voir pour eux alors que nous savons que
effectivement il y a des liens et donc
c'est très important de de qu'il puisse
comprendre cela et c'est pour cela que
moi je reste persuadé que la première
des choses c'est
effectivement convaincre les joueurs
mais pour convaincre les joueurs il faut
convaincre la fédération de mettre en
place certaines choses en équipe de
France notamment par exemple l'équipe de
France on va prendre l'équipe de France
A lorsque vous arrivez enéquipe de
France A normalement il aurait fallu que
vous soyez éduqué
déjà à travers les équipes de jeunes à
prendre des des positions contre les
choses injustes injustes mais il faut
que la Fédération puisse vous
l'autoriser ça veut dire que si dans
toutes les les les équipes de jeunes et
tous les ans il y a une sensibilisation
autour des problématiques ça veut dire
que eux ils vont grandir et peut-être
que quand ils vont arriver dans l'équipe
a en fait ce sera naturel de dire
certaines choses mais vous avez été
accompagné par l'institution en
fait et encore une fois j'ai été joueur
de foot lorsque j'ai commencé à prendre
position sur certaines choses des
dirigeants des entraîneurs sont venus me
voir pour me dire d'arrêter de parler de
ça il faut que vous le sachiez que c'est
OK parce que tu représent un club ça
veut dire qu'il y a aussi quand vous
avez un maillot vous n'êtes pas votre
propre vous êtes pas seul en fait vous
représenter un club donc ça veut dire ce
que vous dites en fait potentiellement
le club peut être en
désaccord donc c'est pour ça que c'est
plus compliqué qu'on le pense et donc
lorsque vous vous avez compris ce
mécanisme vous pouvez vous dire à votre
club écoutez en fait moi je vais dire ce
que j'ai envie de
dire mais pour dire ce que vous avez
envie de dire il faut aussi être
euh un type de joueur parce que tous les
joueurs ne peuvent pas le faire quand
vous êtes un grand joueur considéré
comme un grand joueur vous pouvez le
faire mais c'est une éducation qui vous
emmène à lutter
contre votre propre votre propre
institution et c'est pour ça que je
parle de d'éducation et très souvent on
va demander des choses aux joueurs on va
dire non mais il faut arrêter il faut
faut dire ça il faut faire ça et ben la
plupart en fait ils ne font rien parce
que ils ne veulent pas de
problème parce que ils savent très bien
que peut-être que le club ne va pas être
d'accord sur ce même sujet d'ailleurs
monsieur Noël Legret s'était prononcé
contre le brassard de de soutien le port
du brassard de soutien à la cause LGBT
craignant de faire passer les joueurs
pour des donneurs de leçon étiez-vous
personnellement favorable au port de ce
brassard on avez-vous discutter avec
Noël Leret et avez-vous regretté que la
FIFA décide finalement d' d'interdire le
port d'un tel brassard au motif qu'
n'était pas fourni par
elle alors j'étais pas euh je veux dire
j'ai pas j'ai pas discuté avec Monsieur
le de ces sujets euh pour moi c'est
toujours important de dénoncer les
injustices donc euh moi je suis pour
tout acte qui pourrait euh faire avancer
les choses après encore une fois j'ai
été joueur de foot je suis conscient que
au fait ce n'est pas que du foot surtout
lorsqu'on parle de Coupe du Monde c'est
des enjeux d'argent et politique donc je
suis conscient de cela vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'està dire que et et
d'ailleurs à partir du moment où la
Fédération va interdire quelque chose
mais il y aura aucun joueur qui va le
faire parce que là aussi vous
représentez un club vous représentez un
maillot mais ça ne veut pas dire que les
joueurs n'auraient pas voulu le faire ça
veut dire que il y a quelqu'un au-dessus
de vous qui vous dit voilà voilà notre
positionnement et à partir du moment où
vous êtes dans dans un collectif ben
vous acceptez même si vous ne partagez
pas ces
idées c'est pour ça que je dis que
beaucoup de choses doit venir de la
fédération et éduquer les joueurs à
savoir que que effectivement parce que
quand vous allez pas dans le sens de
votre autorité il y a des récupértion il
y a il y a des comment je pourrais dire
ça il y a des conséquences nous sommes
d'accord chacun de nous on le sait très
bien donc ça veut dire qu'il faut que
éduquer les joueurs à savoir en fait
est-ce qu'ils acceptent les conséquences
et parfois il y a des joueurs des
sportifs historiquement d'accord
historiquement il y a eu des joueurs ben
en fait qui ont été contre l'institution
ils ont payé le prix et c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'encore une fois c'est très
intéressant de connaître l'histoire même
des luttes pour la justice à travers le
sport par exemple si vous connaissez
l'histoire de Mohamed Ali en fait
peut-être que vous vous allez raisonner
différemment si vous connaissez
l'histoire des athlètes américains lors
de des Jeux olympiques de 76 vous allez
réagir agir différemment c'est pour ce
que je dis que c'est une question
d'éducation être éduqué ça souvent ça
vous met en mouvement vous n'êtes pas
obligé de subir mais si vous avez des
athlètes extrêmement éduqués sur tous
ces
sujets ça met en danger attention hein
bah bien sûr il y a mais ça c'est dans
tous les
domaines non c'est enfin c'est
passionnant hein euh c'est c'est
vraiment euh mais je je alors on va
essayer d'aller un peu un peu au fond
des choses parce que moi j'entends là
tout ce que tout ce que vous dites et et
je voudrais soulever
quelques quelques paradoxes quelques
petit paradoxe euh parce que vous dites
enfin vous venez de terminer en
disant en gros il faut pas que les les
les joueurs soient trop éduqués parce
que sinon ça ça ça
pose
oui oui j'ai j'ai oui
j'ai mais le fait qu' le le le fait le
fait qu'il puisse l'être et j'ai bien
compris que vous plaidiez pour qu'il le
soit mais le fait le fait qu'il puisse
l'être pourrait effectivement ébranler
un peu le ébranler un peu le système
c'est c'est un c'est un constat mais non
là où j'ai j'ai on peut avoir un
désaccord je pense c'est et au final
c'est pas c'est pas très c'est pas très
grave c'est que
euh vous avez dit bah oui euh si on
n'est pas en phase avec l'institution il
y a des conséquences c'est vrai dans le
football mais c'est vrai dans tous les
dans tous les secteurs dans toutes les
domaines et dans tous les secteurs
d'activité
alors moi je suis un peu surpris de ça
parce que ça enfin éducation certes mais
on a l'impression et et on est ici nous
ne sommes ni naïfs ni dupes de de ce que
représente le football mais le sentiment
que cela donne c'est que justement il
est il pèse tellement il est tellement
important pour tout ce qu'on vient de se
dire que cette ce plafond de verre ne
sera au final jamais brisé et c'est ça
qui
euh c'est c'est c'est ça qui qui est qui
est qui est qui qui est un peu
déstabilisant parce que oui moi je crois
je le redis je crois qu'il faut un choc
et le choc il ne peut à mon sens venir
pour que ce soit pour que ce soit
vraiment
euh su de manière très large je pense
qu'il ne peut venir que de ceux qui ont
le plus de notoriété et au auprès de qui
on se réfère le plus vous avez raison de
dire que que il y a plein d'autres
acteurs mais que ce soit les présidents
de club les arbitres au final d'un point
de vue de la notoriété qui les connaît
peu de personnes encore une fois dans le
microcosme du du football et et
peut-être du sport de manière un peu
plus large mais les noms dont on vient
dont on est en train de parler euh quand
en
1998 vous gagnez la coupe du monde
lilianturam il est évidemment
mondialement connu Zinedine Zidane il
est mondialement connu Didier deschan
Laurent Blanc enfin Marcel de sailli et
cetera et cetera donc évidemment que
vous avez une une une
responsabilité elle est très importante
et euh et c'est vrai que moi ça m' moi
qui suis vraiment un fan de foot ça ça
m'interroge ça m'a toujours interrogé et
25 ans
après j'ai l'impression mais peut-être
est-ce que je me trompe qu'on n' pas
beaucoup avancer parce
que à vous entendre et je pense que ce
que vous dites évidemment la la réalité
ce poids est toujours
omniprésent que les fédérations que les
clubs au
final ne se sont pas réellement emparés
du sujet ettouffent quelque peu pe
quelque peu les les les affaires vous
disiez d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure dans le parcours de du du futur
international si tentait d'ailleurs
qu'il qu'il soit dans toutes les équipes
de France de tous les niveaux ce qui est
loin d'être le cas de de tous les
joueurs et vous le savez mieux que nous
le parcours se fait aussi au sein des
centres de formation des clubs mais vous
nous avez dit aussi tout à l'heure que
vous lors de vos passages dans
différents clubs on est venu vous dire
bah écoute lilion là tu tu te tais c'est
pas la politique du club où on veut pas
que le club soit
éclaboussé
donc quand vous nous dites ça moi je me
dit bah donc c'est vrai au sein de la
féd au travers des 18 je crois que c'est
18 équipe nationale qu'on nous a cité
tout à l'heure et c'est vrai aussi au
sein des clubs professionnels donc on
fait quoi on fait
comment tout d'abord ce que vous
raconter ça peut être vrai dans votre
cadre de
travail d'accord c'està-dire que le
football encore une fois ok n'est pas
hors société nous sommes
d'accord donc ça veut dire ce qui se
passe en dehors c'est exactement la même
chose avec le foot c'est pour cela que
je dis que je suis pour l'éducation des
joueurs pour qu'ils comprennent qu'il
comprennent qu'effectivement il peut
faire changer les choses
ou je ne suis pas d'accord c'est que on
oublie de mettre la responsabilité sur
ceux qui sont en charge de changer les
choses si le racisme perdure par exemple
dans nos
sociétés en fait c'est pas lié aux
individus hein en fait c'est lié au
discours politiques ça veut dire ce sont
les discours politiques qui légitiment
des discours racistes dans notre société
et que le racisme perdure ce sont les
discours politiques qui légitiment aussi
le sexisme dans c ok donc en fait moi je
fais partie de ceux qui regardent tout
en haut et qui question question tout en
haut avant de questionner effectivement
certains acteurs et c'est là qu'il a
qu'il a peut-être un décalage
c'est-à-dire que j'essaie d'éduquer en
disant chacun de nous nous devons nous
éduquer à prendre la parole à dénoncer
les choses à comprendre à se mettre en
mouvement mais je n'oublie pas que ceux
qui sont garants totalement du
changement c'est ceux qui sont dessus et
qu'il faut les
questionner
ouais juste de petits points de
précision vous enfin ceux qui sont tout
en haut vous avez vous avez raison mais
dans ceux qui sont tout en haut il y a
aussi des joueurs de foot professionnels
en tous les cas pour certains à minima
les internationaux c'est quand même
enfin vous le savez mieux que nous vous
êtes adulé pour pour pour la plupart
d'entre vous vous êtes vous êtes suivi
vous avez c'était pas votre qu'à
l'époque mais aujourd'hui les les les
joueurs de foot ont des si tantait que
ce soit un critère mais çaen est
forcément un pour une certaine franche
de la population ont des milliers de
followers sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux et cetera et cetera et donc ça
c'est c'est juste un élément de de de de
d'analyse partagée ou pas d'ailleurs
donc oui sur sur ce que vous avez dit
sur le discours politique mais d'abord
aujourd'hui tout est politique donc bon
je je enfin moi moi je je je crois
beaucoup en en l'exemple
emplarité voilà des uns et des autres ça
c'était c'était le le le premier point
de de de que je voulais soulever et non
je je revenais tout à l'heure sur je
voulais revenir brièvement
sur ce que vous nous avez dit
sur l'éducation quand vous dites encore
faudrait-il que les joueurs sachent ce
que c'est que le racisme ce que c'est
que le que le sexisme l'homophobie et
cetera et
cetera là aussi ça m'interroge un peu
parce que je me dis enfin on est quand
même dans un monde où on est tous
informés surinformé désinformé
d'ailleurs parfois vous croyez
sincèrement c'est une question vraiment
il y a pas de il y a pas de de
d'arrièrepenser du tout pensez
sincèrement qu'en 2023 quand on est
international par exemple on sait pas ce
que c'est que l'homophobie le sexisme et
le racisme si tantit qu'on en est déjà
si tantit que pour certains il n'en a
pas été
victime excusez-moi je peux vous poser
une
question la France a eu des lois
racistes pendant combien
d'années
vous pouvez pas répondre à cette
question non mais c'est pour ça donc
vous voyez bien que si je vous pose une
question sur le racisme par exemple je
demande notre pays a des lois racistes
pendant combien de temps vous ne sa pas
vous pouvez pas y répondre en fait c'est
ça le racisme c'est comprendre c'est
connaître en fait les mécanism c'est pas
simplement subir le racisme parce que
vous pouvez subir le racisme et ne rien
comprendre à l'histoire du racisme
si vous voulez parler du racisme il faut
connaître le Code noir il faut connaître
le code de l'indigéna il faut savoir que
en fait le monde moderne s'est
construite sur ces hiérarchies selon la
couleur de la peau et qu'en fait il y
avait des
lois si je vous parle de de la police
des noir en France peut-être que vous ne
savez pas que ça existait et donc c'est
pour ça que je dis attention
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on parle du
sexisme de l'homophobie en fait il y a
des choses à savoir et à connaître il
faut pas être dans un dans une certaine
superficial
et c'est pour cela que je dis que être
éduqué à comprendre les mécanismes en
fait c'est fondamental pour se mettre en
mouvement pour comprendre
qu'effectivement tout d'abord tout
changement advient grâce à une minorité
de gens parce que très souvent les
joueurs vont se dire je nous ne sommes
pas assez nombreux bah déjà ils ont tort
parce qu'en fait c'est pas le nombre qui
fait la différence c'est une minorité
qui fait changer les choses mais la
plupart des gens ne connaissent pas
l'histoire donc ils ne savent pas
comment appréhender les choses donc
c'est pour cela que je pour répondre à
votre question oui en 2023 la grande
majorité des gens ne connaissent pas
l'histoire du racisme et donc ne
connaissent pas les stratégies de lutte
pour
avancer non mais
attendez oui mais vous non connaître le
racisme je vous dis encore une fois on
peut
faire les c que je vous dis on peut et
peut-être que vous vous ne voyez pas le
racissement vous allez pas analyser ça à
travers le racisme peut-être que vous
allez pas voir que c'est un acte
homophobe peut-être que vous allez pas
voir que c'est un acte sexiste parce
qu'en fait vous n'êtes pas éduqué à
comprendre en fait et c'est pour cela
que lorsqu'on parle de ces sujets là et
quand je parle d'éducation c'est
aller analyser les choses avec sérieux
et analyser la société dans laquelle
nous vivons aujourd'hui et tirer le fil
pour comprendre que ça vient d'un passé
par exemple lorsquon parle de problème
de
racisme vous savez ce
sont la construction de certaines
catégories qui créent problème
d'accord je vous poser une are question
vous êtes
blanc ok depuis quand vous êtes
blanc 49 ans vous êtes
blanc vous êtes blanc comme ça ou pas
d'accord en fait ça appte en souris mais
être blanc c'est une construction en
fait idéologique et politique en fait
c'est ça qu'il faut analyser quand moi
quand je parle de racisme je parle de
choses c'est pas style ouais il s'est
passé non non non en fait
connaître et la Fondation c'est ça c'est
connaître l'origine en fait notre façon
de penser de de réfléchir li à des
catégories et effectivement quand vous
commencez à déconstruire les catégories
et vous comprenez que c'est une
construction que le blanc le noir
n'existe pas en fait là oui vous pouvez
vous mettre en mouvement et vous allez
vous mettre en mouvement
euh je dirais de honnêtement si c'est
pour dire NON racisme euh non sexisme
non à l'homophobie ah ben c'est très
bien il faut le faire mais ça va pas
avancer rapidement hein et aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on fait en fait et c'est
pour ça que ça n'avance pas parce que
c'est en fait c'est traité d'une façon
extrêmement
superficielle extrêmement superficiel et
donc en fait moi je pense que
sincèrement encore une fois il y a
beaucoup de personnes et encore moi je
suis honnête he je je me dis que les
gens en fait ont des attitudes mais ils
ont pas conscience de ça par exemple
quand Monsieur le dit ouais il y a pas
beaucoup de racisme il y a très peu de
racisme je me dis qu'en fait il est
honnête dans sa dans sa démarche
d'accord il est c'estàd que il est il
est honnête mais il se rend pas compte
de la gravité de ses propos en fait à
quel point c'est super humiliant mais en
même temps il est président de la
Fédération Française de foot peut-être
que lui il veut sauvegarder l'image du
foot parce que en fait il veut donner
une bonne opinion du foot et c'est pour
cela que moi j'essaie toujours de me
mettre à la place de l'autre pour
essayer de comprendre ce que lui dit et
pourquoi il le
dit et donc c'est pour cela que si on
parle sérieusement de ces sujets
effectivement il faut pouvoir en
débattre à la Fédération avec les jeunes
joueurs vous savez vous pouvez être une
personne noire et subir le racisme et ne
rien comprendre au
racisme je sais pas si on se comprend si
si on se comprend enfin en tous les cas
je comprends parfaitement ce que vous
dites et et et merci de ces de ces
précisions effectivement on n'est pas
sur ENF on n pas on n'est pas sur la
même échelle temporelle vous êtes sur le
sur le temps long sur un travail
d'introspection par rapport à à une
histoire et par rapport à à tout ce qui
a pu se passer dans dans nos sociétés et
c'est c'est hyper c'est c'est hyper
intéressant et je pense qu'effectivement
vous avez très clairement identifié
euh ce qui fera sur du plus long terme
qu'on qu'on mettra fin euh aux
situations qu'on est en train de qu'on
est en train d'évoquer pour ne pas
revenir sur tout ce qu'on s'est dit euh
depuis maintenant un peu plus de d'une
heure et demi juste juste dire que euh
nonobstant tout cela il y a quand même
parfois des déclarations et des actes
qui de mon point de vue doivent être
traités sur du temps court voire très
court qui malheureusement ne permettent
pas de faire tout ce travail absolument
nécessaire et bravo de le de le faire au
sein de cette fondation et si on peut
vous aider à ce que ça se développe et
ben évidemment qu'on le fera et c'est en
ce sens que que je
maintiens que que oui les uns les autres
nous aussi hein on a on a une très très
lourde responsabilité ça nous empêche
évidemment pas d'interroger comme vous
le faites et et très bien d'ailleurs
toute l'histoire de nos soci et donc de
ce qui a pu se passer entre les
différents peuples et par rapport à par
rapport au racisme excusez-moi vous
savez juste juste madame la rapporteur
voilà alors moi je vais peut-être
repartir de ce que tu viens de dire moi
je comprends les choses un peu
différemment donc moi ce que je
comprends de ce que vous nous expliquez
et d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant je
vraiment je tenais à vous le dire c'est
la manière dont vous prenez le sujet est
extrêmement intéressante en tout cas
nous c'est ce qu'on ce qu'on se dit
parce que c'est la première fois qu'on
on entend en fait peut-être une
réflexion aussi poussée sur comment
finalement lutter contre le racisme
parce que vous l'avez dit en tout cas
nous ce qu'on constate c'est que ça fait
30 40 50 ans que ça dure il y a pas eu
d'évolution au contraire certains
joueurs ont même dit que ça c'était
aggravé dans certains dans certains
sports moi ce que je comprends de ce que
vous dites c'est que finalement faire
des
ateliers comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
d'information peut-être de prévention et
juste dire aux gens bah en fait le
racisme c'est mal l'homophobie c'est pas
bien sans déconstruire les mécanismes
qui conduisent à ce qui est des
phénomènes raciste ou homophobe ou
sexiste dans notre société et bien en
fait ce n'est finalement qu'une forme
d'affichage qui en fait ne fait pas un
travail de fond qui permet de changer la
société en profondeur et qui permet
d'avancer en réalité et donc d'avoir des
résultats très précis sur la lutte
contre le racisme l'homophobie ou le
sexisme moi c'est comme ça que je le
comprends et c'est en ça que je trouve
que votre approche elle est extrêmement
importante et même si effectivement
peut-être que la déconstruction prend du
temps en réalité je pense qu'il faut
tenir les de bouts c'està-dire que il
faut les sanctions il faut l'information
mais il faut la déconstruction parce que
sinon on changera pas la société et ben
écoutez moi je pense je pense exactement
bien évidemment comme vous vous savez
dernièrement j'étais
euh je lisais les
journaux et je vais essayie d'être tout
calme parce que là je je me sens que
l'émotion me prend
vous savez il y a eu cette histoire des
maillots arc-en-ciel
d'accord il y a un entraîneur qui a fait
une sortie surréaliste surréaliste il a
dit qu'en fait qu'il fallait arrêter ça
parce qu'en fait il y avait des joueurs
qui ne voulaient pas jouer et en fin de
saison le maintien pouvait se jouer à un
ou deux points et qu'il fallait arrêter
ça mais la personne qui dit ça ne se
rend pas compte c'est quoi l'homophobie
en fait le mec qui te parle d'un point
ou deux un point ou deux en fin de
saison mais c'est pas c'est pour ça que
je vous dis mais il faut qu'on que
quelqu'un le voir et lu lui explique
c'est quoi l'homophobie l'homophobie
c'est de la violence c'est le droit de
tuer des gens c'est des gens qui sont en
prison pour ce qu'ils sont c'est du
mépris dans ta propre famille qui te met
à la rue c'est des enfants qui se
retrouvent à la rue c'est ça
l'homophobie c'est pas c'est c'est
c'est exact mais si vous donnez le
maillot arcenciel aux gens sans leur
expliquer en fait c'est quoi
l'homophobie mais en fait ils
comprennent
pas ils comprennent pas en fait ils
comprennent pas aussi pourquoi c'est si
répandu dans la société il y a des
enfants qui se suicide en
fait parce qu'ils sont homosexuels mais
ils se suicident à cause de qui
mais à cause de
nous c'est ça qu'il faut dire aux gens
il y a des enfants qui se suicident et
toi tu tu tu tu donc ça veut dire que
lui ne sait pas ce que c'est
l'homophobie il sait pas et donc c'est
pour cela que il faut qu'on puisse
l'expliquer mais moi quand je lis ça je
me dis non mais en fait on aa on a pas
expliqué aux joueurs en fait les gens en
fait ils participe à un truc mais ils
savent pas la gravité de quoi
l'homophobie tu peux être dans une
famille table et tes parents peuvent
sortir des propos super homophobes parce
que toi ils savent pas que toi tu es
homoexuel le racisme de la couleur de la
peau c'est pas la c'est pas pareil
c'està-dire que si vous êtes à table en
famille il y a pas quelqu'un qui va vous
insulter sur votre couleur parce que
vous êtes de la même famille mais
l'homophobie ça peut être vécu dans la
famille mais oui mais il y a il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ne savent pas et
donc c'est pour cela que si vous
demandez aux gens de participer à un
truc qui ne comprennent pas ils ne
comprennent pas la gravité des choses et
donc moi l'idée c'est effectivement ok
on veut changer les choses mais il faut
comprendre la gravité des choses et pour
cela bah il faut il faut discuter
sereinement tranquillement débattre pour
comprendre et comprendre parfois ça
prend pas ça prend pas beaucoup de temps
hein mais lorsque vous avez compris
c'est
àe lorsque vous avez compris c'est avis
vous n'avez plus d'autrees choix
parce que vous voyez ce qu'il y a
derrière c'est pas simplement un
maillot mais qui leura expliqué
peut-être
personne merci sincèrement merci
Monsieur lianturam pour votre prestation
pour vos propos c'était poignant pour
comment dirais-je j'ai déjà dit que les
témoignages étaient poignant quand une
victime s'exprimait notamment une
victime de de violence sexuelle ou
sexiste et nous en avons reçu quelques
quelques-unes bien souvent des
femmes mais la violence elle s'exprime
aussi au travers de du constat que vous
en faites et je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir participé à cette commission
d'enquête n'hésitez pas à revenir vers
nous si vous souhaitez compléter et
surtout faire des propositions aussi de
à cette commission merci écoutez je vous
remercie merci beaucoup